and left for me in my bed head look at
this bed head she's out of it alright
whatever what you see is what you get I
look this is me admitting that I roll
out of bed afternoon that's a lie for
the YouTuber right there woke up found
out there was a new trailer for x-men
apocalypse this [ __ ] is out of control
of this boy they're gonna what for now
the movie comes out next month it's
probably gonna be another 1i my last
trailer review always joking about it I
was like there's gonna be another one
but there really should not be how many
times can we hear the one
everything they've built will fall and
how many times can we see xavier gets
splattered by apocalypse you know like
the game well let's start talking about
this trailer because the trailer does
have a couple of new things that are
worth talking about a couple of lines of
dialogue so to speak it starts out with
the whole like yeah he's apocalypse he's
big he's bad he's coming shits gonna get
real hello ever there's this great scene
where Xavier is looking at magneto and
he's like Erick don't join them in
magneto Erik Lehnsherr responds with
whatever you think you saw in me I
buried it with my family now that could
mean Holocaust family absolutely however
it does show him clutching someone who
was obviously dead and anis makes a fist
as possible to Erik Lehnsherr found
himself a wife had some kids maybe maybe
indeed out of the air the entire recipe
of magneto just does scream dad of the
year so why not I do like the fact that
Quicksilver came out and decide yeah
Magneto's my dad it was a cool Easter
egg in Days of Future past and this one
he's like yep he's my pops take that
Marvel Cinematic Universe is my dad your
Quicksilver is dead however I wonder if
that's gonna play into the dynamic of
this movie if magneto lost his family
now that he has a son Quicksilver maybe
his son Quicksilver could be like dad
don't do this maybe that'll snap him out
of it who knows sounds cheesy when I say
it I'm saying like if you take that
concept and then give it to a director
who can make it good hey cool it
showcases what will probably be some
great action sequences in this movie
which I should be praising them for I
mean I'm here bitching about the fact
that all the trailers are kind of the
same but the alternative is what they
show us new stuff and spoil the entire
movie in the course of their trailer
campaigns is there any winning with we
youtubers probably not so I'm going to
be optimistic and I'm gonna take the
fact that these x-men apocalypse
trailers are pretty much all the same
I'm gonna take it as a positive is
they're not spoiling it for us so I
think that is cool however if the movie
has no depth to it I'm just gonna be
irritated as [ __ ] and then the end has
what is a little glimpse an easter egg a
secret a surprise to everybody it's kind
of a spoiler I mean go watch the trailer
and then come back and I'll talk about
it here but who are we kidding it's cool
yeah a little help that's right
Wolverines back with his class metal
claws not like you know bone claws I'm
sure actually you see that right there
that pose yeah that's perfect for the
thumbnail not gonna put it
because I'm not a [ __ ] bag who would
want to ruin that for people tweeters
witness x-men apocalypse - it's cool yes
Fox we haven't forgotten about the movie
I know Marvel is huge thing right now
Civil War is coming out but yeah the
x-men is still it's on our minds a
trailer every month to remind us I don't
know that that's necessary but I can't
deny I'm looking forward to this movie
because like x-men great Bryan Singer's
excellent movies great apocalypse
[ __ ] great so let's make with the
apocalypse right so the new x-men
apocalypse trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see moe